wir alle wissen es die Digitalisierung
in Deutschland ist ein absolutes
Armutszeugnis warum ist das so genau das
fragen wir gleich den Bundeskanzler guck
mal da hinten kommt er schon hier her
Bundeskanzler hier schauen Sie
mal Herr Dr
K nur weil sie jetzt überall Kupferkabel
verlegen lassen wird die deutsche
Digitalisierung 2024 völlig im Arsch
sein Kupferkabel was soll das überhaupt
sie keine andere frag D fragen Sie mal
wenigstens richtig B ich entstehen sind
derlage eine Frage zu stellen wissen Sie
überhaupt was das Internet ist ja oder
anders gefragt ist ihn Digitalisierung
überhaupt wichtig aber ob ihen wichtig
ist für die Sendung da habe ich meine
Zweifel denn schon so wie sie jetzt das
ganze mit einem habenen Lächeln
begleiten ist s offenbar dass ihr nicht
an einer Nachricht interessiert sind
dann was ganz anderes was halten sie von
Friedrich März jetzt wünsche ich noch
einen guten
morgenes
g
achtung spoileralarm das mit der
Digitalisierung in Deutschland läuft gar
nicht
[Musik]
gut gut es gibt ein paar exotische Orte
wo alles reibungslos funktioniert aber
im Alltag trifft man immer häufiger auf
Menschen die das Faxen dicke haben Gott
sei Dank werden sich jetzt Fachleute
drum kümmern das Innenministerium das
ist ja zuständig für die Digitalisierung
der Ver
wussten sie das
eigentlich natürlich weiß ich das ach
komm wird auch total viel digitalisiert
gar nicht mehr so schlecht es ist
natürlich zu wenig es passiert ja
langsam was aber stimmt das ist ein Witz
was machen Sie denn
hier ja das ist eine gute Frage die
stelle ich mir natürlich auch immer
wieder eine Reise durch ein
traumatisiertes Land und die Frage wie
konnte das alles passieren LZ ja ja wie
konnte das alles
passieren
na sitzen sie auch gerade zu Hause und
müssen ztf schauen weil das Internet mal
wieder zu schlecht ist um was Geiles zu
streamen ganz genau ganz genau dabei
hätte das nicht sein müssen denn schon
1981 beschloss Bundeskanzler Helmut
Schmidt den Bau eines bundesweiten
Glasfasernetzes und falls Sie sich jetzt
fragen wo ist das bundesweite
Glasfasernetz tja das hat Schmitz nach
Folger Helmut Kohl dann 1983 gestoppt
stattdessen ließ Kohl Kupferkabel
verlegen weil kein wit darüber gab es
auch Kabelfernsehen und der Kanzler
wollte Konkurrenz den ARD und ZDF waren
ihm zu links den Zustand der deutschen
Digitalisierung verdanken wir also
linksgrün versiffen Öffis und Helmut
Kohl verdanken wir das
hier na ja wie sagt man so schön hätte
hätte Faxgeräte nur leider ist auch über
40 Jahre später wenig passiert im
aktuellen digitalisierungsindex der EU
sind wir nur auf Platz 13 und erst im
September schinigte die EUKommission uns
bei der Versorgung mit Glasfaser sehr
schwere Menge danke noch mal die
traurige Wahrheit auch heute stellen
sich selbst die besten deutschen ialer
viel zu oft die Frage bin ich da schon
drin oder was
[Musik]
nein so liebe Zuschauer jetzt nehme ich
sie mit auf eine Reise in unbekannte
Welt es gibt nämlich immer noch Orte in
Deutschland die kaum Internet klar da
muss man schon bisschen rausfahren
richtig in die Pampa
hinein Spaß 30 km hinter Köln Kreis Loma
das ist niich
[Musik]
absurd fr Lomberg Herr Köster worauf
warten Sie denn auf schnelles Internet
ja seit Jahren können Sie lange warten
was ist denn genau das Problem hier das
ist ein ganz schöner Akt war hier
überhaupt irgendeine Art von Internet
hinzukriegen aber ich habe jetzt gesehen
dass hinten ist ja eine Baustelle da
wird ja Glasfaser verlegt ja ja ja ja
das ist super das ist ganz toll also man
kann jetzt auch schon überall an die
Baustellen da kann man überall hingucken
wir sind praktisch umzingelt von diesen
Baustellen wo Glasfaser gelegt wird aber
hier halt
nicht ja dann ziehen sie doch um nee das
wollen wir nicht wie lange leben sie
schon hier seit 5 Jahren leben wir jetzt
hier und
seit wann haben Sie überhaupt eine Art
Internet hier also zuverlässig ist so
dass man eine Seite öffnen kann oder so
z.B
ja seit zi Jahren seit gut zi Jahren
also sie haben dre Jahre quasi hier ja
wir haben unsol spel gelebt ja ja
sozusagen ja und dann haben wir uns
umgehört und es gibt ja wirklich einen
Anbieter der per Funk des Internet ins
hausort und seitdem haben wir Internet
meistens per Funk per Funk kann ich mir
das mal angucken na klar gerne da bin
ich ja mal gespannt also das ist jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen ungewöhnlich
aber es funktioniert das ist jetzt hier
ihr Internet n das ist unser Internet
das kommt das läuft durchs bet von der
Funkantenne hier
dann über den Hof und dort zum Fenster
rein und sie haben Kabel das dann da in
ihr Fenster ja ja reingeht ja in ihr
Windows quasi könnte man sagen ne genau
aber wo führt denn das Kabel hin ja ist
ein kleines Stück wollen wir okay
[Musik]
gut
wir sind da ja wir sind da endlich wow
unfassbar was ist das das ist also ich
kann ihn das technisch jetzt nicht
wirklich erklären das ist das
Empfangsteil also da kommt das Signal an
dass dort in ein Kilometer Entfernung
vom Bauernhof gesendet wird der hat eine
auch eine Parabolantenne das Sendegerät
praktisch also das heißt sie zapfen
eigentlich das Internet vom Bauern da
drüben an ja das tun mehrere ja das ist
legal und absolut so gewollt aber was
jetzt meine Sorge ist in diesem
Zusammenhang ich meine ich liebe die
Natur sonst würde ich ja nicht hier
wohnen aber diese Bäume das Wachstum der
Bäume macht mir Sorgen wenn diese buchen
wachsen und dann im Frühjahr ab Frühjahr
Blätter haben dann haben wir keine
Sichtachse mehr zu dieser zu diesem
Sendeteil des Bauern und dann ist
Schluss mit Internet jetzt ist die Frage
was ist schneller ja die Regierung oder
die buchen wenn die Bäume wachsen haben
sie kein Internet wenn die Bäume wachsen
haben wir kein Internet da habe ich ein
Geschenk für sie ach nein wir haben uns
nicht lumpen lassen großartig ja viel
Spaß weil besser kann man die deutsche
Digitalisierung nicht zusammenfassen
viel Glück und viel Sägen das ist es
doch sie schaffen das
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
danke
[Applaus]
und jetzt aufgepasst es gibt tatsächlich
deutsche die sind mit der
Digitalisierung richtig zufrieden aber
die Leben auch nicht in Deutschland
sondern in Estland Florian Markus ist
hier digitalisierungsberater denn
estland ist quasi das digitalste Land
Europas zum Alltag gehören hier sogar
selbstfahrende Busse ein selbstfahrender
Bus wow in Deutschland ist ein fahrender
Bus schon
Sensation und auch das e-rezept gibt es
hier seit dem 1 Januar also seit dem 1
Januar 2010 denn hier setzt man wirklich
alles auf eine Karte und das ist eben
mein Personalausweis meine
Gesundheitskarte mein Führerschein meine
paybackkte für den Einzelhandel es ist
alles mit dieser Personalausweis
verbunden oder wie wir in Deutschland
sagen unmöglich so und jetzt kommt wenn
man in Estland mal zum Amt muss dann
macht man einfach den Computer an Moment
Moment Moment wie soll das denn gehen
behördengäe Internet jetzt verarsch du
mich doch dafür bräuchte man ja eine Art
esnisches staatsportal und dann kommt
man auf das esnische staatsportal und
dann sieht man hier schon sofort die
sogenannten Live Events das heißt eine
bestimmte Situation in meinem Leben ist
passiert ich habe ein Kind bekommen ich
bin krank geworden und dann damit
verbunden alle verschiedenen
Dienstleistungen dieses staatsportal
bündelt alle verschiedenen
Dienstleistungen ist aber im Endeffekt
nur ein ich sag mal digitales
Aushängeschild wo man dann zu den
verschiedenen Behörden weitergeleitet
wird in Deutschland wird man auch von
Behörde zu Behörde weitergeleitet aber
halt analog physisch vor Ort ja nein das
wäre hier schon leichter wie viel
Prozent der staatlichen Dienstleistung
sind online kann man das sagen wir haben
99,9% der staatlichen Dienstleistung
online es gibt ich sag mal zwei grobe
Ausnahmen und das ist Heirat und
schcheidung das sind so halbdigitale
Dienstleistung wo man vorher schon alles
digital anmelden kann aber das ja oder
auch das neinwort muss dann noch vor Ort
g also die beiden glücklichsten Momente
im Leben diese sind noch weiterhin
analog absolut ich habe nach der Geburt
unserer Tochter eine Benachrichtigung
vom Start bekommen alles gute zur Geburt
des Kindes auf welches Konto geht das
Kindergeld also keinen Antrag keine
Anmeldung irgendwo es ist einfach nur
wir wissen dass das Geld zusteht wohin
schicken wir das Geld und das ist
einfach diese dieses Level von
Dienstleistung dass ich hier vom Start
erwarten würde ich bin in Deutschland
und auch anderswo bitsteller ich muss
dem Staat beweisen dass ich dieses Kind
tatsächlich habe und dementsprechend
auch Anspruch auf die diese Leistung
habe und das ist einfach ja eine ganz
andere Beziehung die so aufgebaut wird
und auch ein anderes
Vertrauensverhältnis denke ich wir
Deutschen sind ja gar nicht ängslich
wenn es darum geht ausländischen Konzern
unsere Daten zu geben wie Facebook das
klappt wenn der eigene Staat Daten haben
will drehen wir komplett durch haben die
est ein anderes Verhältnis zum
Datenschutz in Estland gibt es ein
anderes Verhältnis zum Thema Datenschutz
in Estland habe ich einen sogenannten
datatacker wo ich jedes einzelne mal
sehen kann welche Behörde hat wann aus
welchem Grund welchen Teil meines
Datensatzes angekomt und wenn ich
irgendwo sehe dass vielleicht ein
Zugriff illegal war dann kann ich direkt
zum datenschutzinspektorat gehen und
dann nehmen sie sich der Sache an um wie
viel Jahre würden Sie sagen ist Estland
Deutschland voraus momentan ziemlich
genau 20 Jahre also ich hoffe dass ich
das beschleunig die nächsten Jahre aber
momentan gibt es noch ein zwei
Zweifel mit diesen neuen Informationen
im Gepäck fahre ich nach Jena denn dort
warten schon Bundeskanzler Scholz
digitalminister Wissing und
Wirtschaftsminister habbeck sehen auf
meine Hilfe denn ich bin heute beim
großen digitalgipfel und der biet die
Möglichkeit Zitat direkt mit der
Bundesregierung zu interagieren ja ich
freue mich auf intensive Gespräche und
ich glaube das auch möglich ist das
merkt man hier z.B an dieser
absperrkordel oder hier an den 1000
Security Leuten also ich freue mich auf
diese direkte Interaktion herr Scholz
finden Sie die Digitalisierung läuft im
deutschlandtempo
auch beim Fototermin ist noch kein
Gespräch möglich doch ich hatte mich mit
Volker Wissing am Kaffeestand verabredet
also dachte ich zumindest ja gut da ist
[Musik]
er Digitalisierung heißt in Deutschland
dass der digitalminister analog vor mir
wegläuft erst die eine Treppe
[Musik]
rauf dann oben über den Gang
zurück
die andere Treppe wieder
runter und schon sind wir wieder am
Kaffeestand jetzt sind wir einmal im
Kreis
gelaufen auf der Flucht vololker
wissings vor mir während der Minister
auf die Bühne flüchtet habe ich mich zu
seiner Garderobe durchgeschlagen und
wurde davon überraschenderweise nicht
abgehalten und so kommt es doch noch zum
großen exklusiv interv toll dass das
noch geklappt hat hallo haben sie kurz
Zeit für mich was dann warte ich einfach
hier auf sie
okay dann halt meine Paradedisziplin vor
Türen darauf warten dass Politiker
rauskommen hallo guten Tag ja wirklich
freuen sie sich
eigentlich ich komme nicht an sie ran
seh ich w sch
we freuen Sie sich denn über die
Digitalisierung in Deutschland weil
meine Katastrophe die Sie sich mit
anderen Ministerien teilen können ist
gar nicht mehr so schlecht kommen ganz
gut voran ist schon noch schlecht ne
also bei der Verwaltung läuft ja richtig
richtig schlecht und beim
Glasfaserausbau
[Musik]
auch komisch immer wenn es beschissen
läuft will keiner mit uns reden ja
wirklich sehr merkwürdig woran das wohl
liegen könnte in Estland dagegen gibt
uns sogar die Bildungsministerin
persönlich ein Interview warum na ja
plat in der PIs Studie voll
digitalisierte Schulen da bring ein
selbst zwei seriöse spitzenjournalisten
nicht aus der
Ruhe soll wir die Mützen nicht besser
absetzen ja hast
recht program
tig
schzp
est slow make it further so you know you
never
know a b embarrassing actually that you
are so far and we are I know we could
teach you something but other than that
you could teach us something about
building
cars in scho sy
ud
sch can easily see what's going on in
the school because this e digital
platform i teachers are inserting
information
there elternprechtag aha what is that
okay teach
meeting that
as we quite online data
udents are in
Germany for years weing our tax online
and for 15 years we have been Voting
online and doing everything online so
paper is very online is
possible
ger ber
ja
ja die Ampel will bis 2025 die Hälfte
der deutschen Haushalte mit Glasfaser
versorgen und steht aktuell bei
35,6%. doch für diese Statistik zählt
nicht dass ihr zu Hause wirklich ans
Glasfasernetz angeschlossen ist nein es
reicht wenn in 20 m Nähe vom Grundstück
irgendwo Glasfaser liegt ein tolles
Geschenk der Bundesregierung auch sie zu
Hause haben vielleicht schon Glasfaser
ohne Glasfaser zu haben ich gratuliere
Ihnen und ich gratuliere zum Rechentrick
denn in Wahrheit haben in Deutschland
nur 19,3% der Haushalte Glasfaser damit
sind wir EU-weit Vorletzter dort haben
es durchschnittlich schon
56,5%. allein in Spanien schon über 90%
aber jetzt mal was positives dafür haben
wir an einigen Stellen richtig viel
Glasfaser denn statt wie beim Wasser
oder Strom eine gemeinsame Leitung zu
nutzen darf hier zuul Lande jeder
Anbieter sein eigenes Glasfasernetz
bauen dann wird die gleiche Straße an
der gleichen Stelle hintereinander
gleich mehrmals auf und wieder zugemacht
gleich dreh ich durch warum ist das
erlaubt tja da fragen Sie mich was na
auch Lust bekommen eine Straße
aufzureißen dann herzlich willkommen in
wölfrad kennst du schon Glas
Faser kennst du schon Glas Faser dein
highpeed Netz dein Anschluss von morgen
einfach
stabilen oder streamen Rapid rapida im
Moment haben wir in wullfrad mit uns
zusammen vier Anbieter das heißt wir
haben nicht eine Leitung wie man das aus
dem Strom oder Gas aus dem Wasser kennt
sondern wir haben vier bis zu vier
Leitung hier in der Straße aber heißt
das da nicht mal ganz doof gesagt dann
wenn das jetzt hintereinander passiert
muss ja die Straße immer wieder neu
aufgerissen werden ja die wird dann
teilweise bis zu vier Mal aufgerissen in
kurzer Zeit die finden die Nachbarn das
so sorgt zumindestens für Erstaunen bei
bei einigen Einwohnern
weil die natürlich
ja klar innerhalb von kurzer Zeit dann
mehrfach die eine bauschelle vor der
haust haben
soel so
und aber warum verpflichtet der statter
nicht die Unternehmen einfach ein Netz
zu errichten und da wo es
unwirtschaftlich ist kommen Fördermittel
zum Einsatz warum ist das in Deutschland
immer so ein Hickhack das ist eine gute
Frage an die Politik ach so ja stimmt
sie sind ja von dem Stadtwerk ich kurz
vergessen falscher
Ort es tut mir leid das heißt in
Deutschland ist es so jeder der Bock hat
kann die Straße aufreißen und Glasfaser
verlegen obwohl da schon Glasfaser liegt
das ist grundsätzlich möglich ja ja dann
machen wir das doch auch danke für den
Tipp sehr gerne tschüss Zeit wir sind
jetzt Konkurrenten
[Musik]
ja Glasfaser und
Glühwein so preist man das an ja so Pre
man das Glasfaser und Glühwein wir sind
heute von der Aktion Glasfaser und
Glühwein okay wie gut ist ihr Internet
wir haben zwischendurch immer
Bildstörung immer so kleine Rucker
manchmal sind sieinlich überrascht dass
wir uns im Original so fließend bewegen
ne ja das wundert mich auch haben Sie
das schon mitbekommen dass hier in
wölfrad ja auch sogar mehrfach die
Straßen aufgerissen werden ja sicher ist
bei uns
auchem uns auch find sie
[Musik]
das ja darauf
Prost sieh immer schön an den
Straßenrändern und so find du das ja
aufreißen aufreißen geht immer wie
findet die Freundin
das nicht so g SPR oder sehr gut wie
schätzen sie denn die Digitalisierung in
Deutschland insgesamt so ein super ne ne
Katastrophe sein Großvater also er nein
das ist ja mein Baby mein lieblings
hallo also eine Leitung sich
verschiedene
Anbieter wäre super hätten Sie Lust
digitalministerin der Ampel zu werden
jetzt ein unmoralisches Angebot wir
brauchen Leute mit Visionen mit Ideen
wir haben volka Wissing sie müssen es
machen wie heißen sie wie heißen sie
doch das ist die neue digitalministerin
sie macht aus Wuppertal sie können auch
vom Homeoffice aus obwohl sie haben
schlechtes Internet ne es ruckelt ja
kommst du aus wülfrad hier auch ja und
wurde bei dir auch schon mehrfach die
Straße aufgerissen ja aber die machen
das lustig die machen auf ja und dann
legt die eine Gesellschaft legt da
irgendwas rein wieder zu und die legen
aber kein Anschluss ans Haus also nur
die Straße auf und dann kommt die
nächste Gesellschaft und die liegt dann
so eine Verbindung vom vom Haus zu
diesem Rohr was die anderen schon
aufgerissen haben aber da liegt ja gar
nicht das Kabel von der Gesellschaft
drin dann kommt die andere also die
Gesellschaft kommt dann noch mal und
macht das was schon wieder zugemacht
wurde noch mal auf um ihr eigenes Ding
da reinzulegen da soll einer sagen wir
Deutschen hätten keinen Humor oder ich
finde den deutschen Humor super ja ja
wir sehen uns dann wenn wir die Straße
bei Ihnen auf das wird richtig
laut aber aber wie ist das in Estland
ich meine das sind ja auch große Weiten
die jetzt nicht so bewohnt sind ne wie
ist da im Internet also generell hat der
stat die Verpflichtung bis zum letzten
Kilometer Internetkabel anzubieten das
heißt das wird alles aus einer Hand zu
ausgerollt das macht es auch etwas
weniger kompliziert als es in
Deutschland der Fall ist und darüber
hinaus haben wir 99% 4G Abdeckung über
Mobilfunk in Estland also das ist kein
Problem das heißt wir könnten das jetzt
mal checken also wir glauben ihn
natürlich aber wir könnten jetzt mal
weit rausfahren und checken mal ob da
Internet ist oder theoretisch ja ja
können sie gerne schöne esnis Natur
entdecken gibt's viel zu sehen wollen
wir doch mal sehen super ob das alles
hier so toll
ist und so beginnt es nun für eines der
größten TV Experimente der deutschen
Fernsehgeschichte fahren wir tagelang
Richtung Osten ins absolute
Niemandsland wir loten Grenzen aus und
dringen in Landschaften vor die nie ein
Mensch zuvor gesehen hat eine Reise ins
Ungewisse
das ist der Beweis wir sind in Estland
im absoluten nirgendwo und wir können
den ZDF Fernsehgarten
Stream also es gibt natürlich wirklich
keinen rationalen Grund das zu tun aber
man könnte es könen wir wieder gehen
oder die Ampel hat zum 1 Januar 2024 von
ihren digitalpolitischen Vorhaben erst
18% umgesetzt natürlich nur weil Social
Media nicht mitzählt ist Olaf Scholz
gerne Döner klar klar denn das D in
Digitalisierung steht für
Döner dabei haben wir doch seit 2021
endlich einen digitalminister aber der
ist für die meisten digitalvorhaben gar
nicht zuständig ein digitalminister der
nicht für Digitalisierung zuständig ist
WTF wie man im Internet sagt aber dafür
hat Volker wiing ja Zeit um um mich zu
konzentrieren auf andere Dinge oder
vielleicht auch um Musik zu hören
besonders schlimm steht es um die
Digitalisierung der Verwaltung 2017
beschloss die groko das Online
zugangsgesetz kurz ozg damit sollten bis
Ende 2022 575
Verwaltungsdienstleistungen
digitalisiert werden online verfügbar
waren zum Stichtag nur 114 übrigens
online verfügbar bedeutet laut
Innenministerium das bloß der Antrag
online gestellt werden kann selbst wenn
alles weitere analog passiert und und es
reicht zudem wenn das von rund 11000
Kommunen nur eine einzige Macht Frage
ist es wenigstens unter der neuen
zuständigen Innenministerin nennt sie
Feser besser geworden nein nein nein ja
denn auch heute sind immer noch 404
Leistungen gar nicht digitalisiert das
ist also mit Error 404 gemeint dafür
sind wir woanders Spitze zuletzt
verbrauchen die Bundesbehörden 753
Millionen Blätter Papier im Jahr dabei
steht auch im
Koalitionsvertrag eine umfassende
Digitalisierung der Verwaltung voran ja
und und ich esse gerne
dünner jetzt mal eine gute Nachricht
Barf kann man mittlerweile online
beantragen deswegen schaue ich mir jetzt
mal eins dieser Hyper modernen Barf ter
an aber zur Sicherheit bringe ich
trotzdem noch mal ein Drucker mit und
ein stapelpapier man weiß ja
nie sind hauptsachbearbeiter hier im
barfückamt und ich bin erstmal positiv
überrascht sie haben ja ein Computer
jawohl wie man sieht haben wir auch
mittlerweile zwei Bildschirme pro
Arbeitsplatz ich dreh durch um das
Material was die studieren und
zuschicken dann später auch besser
sichten zu können man kann doch Barf
digital beantragen wieso ist denn dann
hier noch so viel Papier das ist richtig
genau der der der Weg bis zur
eigentlichen E-Akte ist noch weit
viele Bundesländer arbeiten mit
unterschiedlichen Betriebssystemen was
das anbelangt die Kopplung untereinander
funktioniert da noch nicht so gut also
wenn ich jetzt BF beantrage beantrage
ich das digital das ja schon mal top
dann kommt das hier digital an genau was
passiert
dann wie viel Seiten werden denn jetzt
hier so pro Tag gedruckt so als
Vorstellung 2500 Packs also 1000 pro Tag
1000 pro Tag heißt über 300000 Pro ja
eine Fichte gibt über 100.000 Blatt 120
000 Blatt das heißt drei
Fichten sterben pro Jahr wegen
mangelnder Digitalisierung nur bei uns
es kommt zwar etwas schon digital rein
aber bei uns das meiste geht eben per
Papier raus aber das nimmt ja wahnsinnig
viel Zeit in Anspruch oder genau wir
haben extra Kolleginnen an der
Poststelle die eben die eingehenden
E-Mails auf die Sachbearbeiter verteilen
und eben ausdrucken und stempeln auch
Stempeln auch noch
also was wir in Deutschland ja brauchen
werden ja eigentlich so ausgebildete
Informatiker und ier um die
Digitalisierung mal voranzubringen aber
ich glaube die warten alle noch auf
ihren barfkantrag oder gut
möglich aber jetzt hat das
Bundesinnenministerium doch so einen
tollen Satz rausgehauen ich möchte mal
vorlesen ich kann das gar nicht glauben
dass es alles nicht klappt weil die
sagen zusätzlich zu der vereinfachten
Beantragung erhalten Antragsstellerin
und Antragssteller nun schneller eine
Antwort und auch die Ämter sparen Zeit
bei der Bearbeitung der Anträge stimmt
nicht nein natürlich nicht nein es ist
im Augenblick unheimlich umständlich
zeitaufwendig so dass wir Sprechzeiten
einschränken mussen dass wir telefontage
festlegen müssen weil unsere Leute sonst
nicht arbeiten können es ist wirklich an
der Belastungsgrenze der Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und tatsächlich hat der
Bundesrechnungshof das auch als
irreführende Information kritisiert weil
es tatsächlich stimmt nicht okay und
jetzt die Emails die du ausgedruckt hast
die ich dir hier mitgebracht habe muss
natürlich den Akten jetzt nicht alles
studierend und ich muss das jetzt in die
Akte der studier genau dasst du tun also
bitte wow wow ich zeige dir den ersten
Namen das gibt doch nicht und such mir
bitte die passende
Akte noch mal zur Erinnerung dieser
Vorgang gilt laut Innenministerium
bereits als
der Antrag wurde ja online gestellt sie
sehen also einen Sortieralgorithmus der
neuesten Generation mich Deutschland hat
die Digitalisierung radikal
verpennt der Föderalismus steht sich an
der Stelle selbst in Weg statt dass der
Bund einfach vorgibt ihr habt die
Software zu nehmen wie ihr sie dann
implementiert ist eure Sache das heißt
ja es gibt vier Software Lösungen in
Deutschland vi verschiedene die nicht
miteinander kommunizieren wenn ich jetzt
in einem Bundesland studiere und dann in
dem anderen heißt das dann passiert was
ja dann wird die Akte per Post hierher
geschickt das heißt Bachelor in Köln
Master in Götting und es wird die Akte
per Papier bewegt Wahnsinn
Wahnsinn Wahnsinn apropos hier in
Estland gibt es natürlich auch noch
Behörden aber die sind ja komplett leer
keine Schlangen keine Wartemarken das
ist ja
Wahnsinn
[Musik]
Mr Ros what's going on h so
empty don't people vis
US
noral
normal not inin in all BU in Estonia in
German
[Musik]
how
longescckck in Germany
alsoion decation
be you have ask
Fried
gerep kind of
paper also paper you
caning
Christmas
Christmas nobody
comes backice
online digitale Verwaltung das ist
eigentlich ganz einfach außer wenn es
Deutschland macht wir haben dieses
Schaubild natürlich längst verstanden
aber für Sie liebe Zuschauer lassen wir
uns das ganze jetzt noch mal erklären
und zwar auf der lemesse für
Digitalisierung auf der Smart country
Convention los
geht's ja leider kein Scherz dieses
Wimmelbild vom normkontrollrat der
Bundesregierung bildet die aktuelle
Digitalisierung der Verwaltung ab ganz
ehrlich wer ist hier für was
[Musik]
zuständig hallo das Innenministerium das
ist ja zuständig für die Digitalisierung
der verwalt
wussten sie das
eigentlich natürlich weiß ich das sie
wussten es wirklich aber das hei gibt ja
zwei Nachrichten die gute Nachricht ist
Volker Wissing ist gar nicht zuständig
und die schlechte sie sind zuständig für
die verwaltungsdigitalisierung ja aber
für den Rest der Digitalisierung ist wir
sing zuständig also du kommst von hier
gehst dann hier steil hoch lässt das
alles aus gehst
hier das wirst du in den Schatten oder
gehst du direkt hierhin okay sie haben
gar keine Ahnung tatsächlich oder wir
sind von der sind bisschen TUM in der
Birne wir haben nicht so ganz verstanden
nicht ganz helle digitale Verwaltung
dabei ist es ja ganz einfach können Sie
uns das kurz anhand dieses Schaubildes
so ein zwei setzen na das Problem bei
Digitalisierung ist wenn der analoge
Prozess kompliziert ist dann wird er
nicht dadurch einfach dass man ihn
digitalisiert warum machen wir das in
Deutschland so dass wir einfach eins zu
eins die Bürokratie digitalisieren ja
z.B als die Bundesrepublik und das
Grundgesetz geschaffen wurde hat man
gesagt der Bund macht die Gesetze die
Länder führen diese Gesetze durch
heutzutage haben wir Computerprogramme
die Gesetze sind immer noch aus der Zeit
der analogen Akte und demzufolge haben
wir nicht ein Computerprogramm auf
Landesebene was was macht sondern 16
unterschiedliche richtig praktisch ist
das nicht das wä aus meiner Sicht etwas
was wir in Zukunft ändern müssen Frau
fer könnten Sie uns nur ganz ganz kurz
die digitale Verwaltung erklären ist
doch so
einfach an und dann sehen sie dass wir
schon große Fortschritte gemacht haben
aber ich freue mich Herr Köster dass Sie
sich interessieren wirklich sie freuen
sich bin er seit zwei Jahren im Amt und
ich habe jetzt viel aufgeholt was in den
letzten Jahren man hat das Gefühl
Digitalisierung hat nicht so ein hohen
Stellenwert bei ihnen ist das so weil
sie auch so viele andere wichtige Themen
haben um die sie sich nicht kümmern nein
ich kümmere mich selbstverständlich um
alle anderen Angelegenheiten vor allen
Dingen um die innere Sicherheit und
die Digitalisierung spielt eine sehr
wichtige Rolle weil wir den Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern es einfacher machen wollen
beispielsweise ein Führerschein zu
beantragen von zu Hause bequem von der
Couch ja falls wir auch mitwachen dürfen
unsere Firma error 404 solutions dan
kmen das ist unsere Firma wir wollen
auch mit nichts tun Geld verdienen bei
der Digitalisierung consting for digital
solutions hier die FDP hat ja mal
plakatiert digital first Bedenken second
wie viel oder genauer gesagt welchen
Teil des Slogans sehen Sie bei der
digitalen Verwaltung umgesetzt ja da
geht immer noch mehr aber z.B ich werde
ja schneller fertig als das Gesetz von
mir verlangt in meinem Ministerium bei
meinen Gerichten er vololk Wissing hat
jetzt beispielsweise die
die die das kfznmernchild digitalisiert
also ich bin auch der Meinung es muss
noch schneller gehen aber wir kommen
jetzt voran wird die FDP die
Digitalisierung Deutschlands noch
erleben ja wir treiben sie ja voran ich
habe ja vorhin schon Beispiele genannt
also ich habe mein Ministerium in einem
Kalenderjahr komplett digitalisiert da
müssen sie mal Behörde zeigen die das
schafft also ich glaube schon dass wir
das ganz gut machen gut dann noch eine
ratefrage zum Schluss wie viel Prozent
der Verwaltungsleistungen waren Ende
letzten Jahres laut Bundesrechnungshof
digitalisiert kleiner Tipp es ist das
nächste FDP Wahlergebnis ach das ist ja
hier jetzt
das ist ja der Versuch mich jetzt so ein
bisschen zu ärgern das verstehe ich ja
alle ja das muss ja auch sein aber ganz
ehrlich es ist natürlich zu wenig na wir
haben die ersten Leistungen ja digital
und ich habe ja im letzten Jahr auch
digitale Antragsverfahren eingeführt
insofern läuft allmählich ja allmählich
weiter tut mir allmählichmlich
allmählich das sind gute Nachrichten es
läuft allmählich endlich schaffen wir
mal was ne mehr war da nicht rauszuholen
die Digitalisierung in Deutschland läuft
allmählich allmählich ja das war wieder
mal schön allmählich bleiben nur noch
drei Fragen offen wird Frau Lomberg auch
in Zukunft im Internet unterwegs sein
ich arbeite dran und gibt es nicht für
all diese Probleme eine einfache Lösung
aufgepasst Deutschland wird digitaler
Vorreiter wenn wir einfach nur tja
schade und wird Lutz fanderhost
weiterhin in esland Fernsehgarten
schauen Lutz kommst du oh nur noch die
eine
Folge oh guck mal der Stream geht wieder
schnell schnell also weitere Videos von
der heuteshow findet ihr hier wenn euer
Internet das
mitmacht abonniert auch gerne den
Kanal